and they were a clean team for the most
part
during the regular season at that combo
in the spin and the hammer
oh my goodness yes and you see that
rotation weak side
not coming at all a tough matchup for
smaller guards and for big guys they
can't keep
up with them off the dribble tj warren
scored 10 of his 19 points in the third
quarter
the lab of the slam but it's jones jr
who will get his first foul this
alley-oop is a 50
how they're gonna get it because they
just certainly haven't been as motivated
as some of these other teams
down the middle goes ac the career show
the white side is going to have to earn
it at the free throw line look at caruso
taking the screen and going to the rim
getting the angle
on white side right side not able to get
over to contest that shot that very very
high level right now
sammy will join us we'll see you at
halftime everybody as we send it over to
studio north once again here's matt
devlin
and jacko jack armstrong look at this
right here hello
big time big time elevation
oh yeah you are on a poster control
shot clock at seven donovan mitchell
dropping it back to royce o'neill nice
shovel inside
what a finish with the physicality still
able to gather
two dribbles inside a track pump plumly
sometimes you need to adjust
even when things are going well because
you know how the other team wants to
attack
and you know philly wanted to go inside
when you were on vacation during the
bubble
we had him miked up for a game and he
was announcing while he was sitting
on the bench and that's his three oh
boston rivers
flies to the rim well austin rivers just
blows by
chris paul and again steven adams
you can't just put your arm out there
vogel comment to me that the lakers need
anthony davis to make threes it helps
their spacing
but you know kentavious oh my gosh
say it with your chest giannis 24 points
18
boards and he is a terror coming at you
[Applause]
good night
that is a wonderful poster hey
gabriel sits down with the two fouls
hassan whiteside comes in
whiteside made some very big plays in
game one alley up to james
and there's anthony davis with a perfect
pass i'm out of the gate
side out of bounds this is a setup you
got to see it if you're the
blazers they don't they allow a direct
dive to the cup
on point pass from anthony davis lebron
james
on a mission early in this ball game
landry shamit got the start tonight oh
two-handed jam
on bobon straight line drive
poster landry shaman listen to this
pow and the rebound by yanis
there comes the mvp to the biscuit
nasty finish back in 2003
anthony was the third pick of that draft
james of course the first nurkic
with the flush there's some contact
there as well anthony davis coming on
the baseline looking to
double team and carmella unselfishly
delivers the pass
anthony davis season opening goes inside
and the foul
aggressive move from davis russo and
anthony davis in the pick and roll
caruso sets the screen late rotation
both teams struggling to shoot early
just two for nine combined leonard
the high percentage shot and he thought
there was contact afterwards
so a three-point game what a shot and
what a finish
by davis dropping a sledgehammer
courtesy of our oculus front row view
that's kind of become the new norm in
the nba powell
nasty indigelous
that is a great dunk but they're letting
powell get to his right hand
and that was by the nuggets so it's been
a
tightly contested game thus far top for
goldberg this again you get into a space
look how far nobody
you don't have anybody deflecting or
trying to get in the way of the pass
that's at 6 30 on tnt
and the blazers and the lakers later
tonight
well they keep matching us hammers it
a little euro action and then some some
talk on the way and that's the
uniqueness
of giannis you can see that play there
that is just
there's not a lot you can do when you
get to the launching pad
but right now still in the indiana
locker room there is hero and it's
stuffed in
by jones jr as he skies in
and stuffs it from miami eight by two
you're watching the nba playoffs on tnt
and it built a great bench this year
with the holiday brothers
doug mcdermott tj mcconnell but the
anchor of their bench unit was actually
a starter
who came back into play with the bench
make it 28 after that last sucker
mitchell
mitchell here just gets by everybody
half-hearted help by michael porter jr
this is donovan
mitchell you can't stay on the side
you've got to get your
body between him and the basket what a
finish
donovan mitchell unleashed i think he's
got to be a little bit closer on the
catch with
with serge that's how well he's shooting
it
wow rob williams who slips and falls
and slow to get up after that marting
after this follow jam but what a
effort he's given again here in game two
for boston
hero lobs and adebayo smashes it over
divincenzo
excellent it's on miami it's a hero
getting more and more confident as a
playmaker just tosses it up he's coming
to his right strong hand he's like okay
giannis has come to me i know the read
to make
just beautiful execution helping
have become the superstars of
the bubble family life and his partner
shantae and williams
hammers one home throw
down on the setup from wada maker man
that is really an explosive move and
this tells you how the game has changed
i'm not sure
i came in the league in the mid 90s as
an assistant in miami
i'm not even sure that's a foul in a uh
knicks series in the
90s and very efficient as well
15 of 19 in the paint morris to zoom out
oh make that 16 of 20.
a little slip action here by morris who
finds zubat
by 10. miami came back and
really now they're trying to stop their
spinning onto the kumbho and that's
going to be a tough chore
well maybe he's finding life
he's the spins on the drive and kick
tucker quarter three
and howard with the rebound
lebron off the boat lebron say it with
your chest
good feed from caruso lebron running the
lane
russell westbrook trying to take the
charge grown man
move wow
express yourself lebron
35 years old yet javale we saw two
kuzma fakes drives and flushes
kyle kuzma
gordon lost the handle picked up by
james back to caruso throws it up
hammer time for lebron james
i mean the steal mike bring calling for
hammer time
lakers regain the lead up four
things to his right gives it right back
and brown
throws it down oh
my goodness jaylen brown have come out
aggressive tonight
dunk of the night thus far
double only two assists away from a
triple double
they double them on the wing porter
taking it home
wow dad likes that one
struggled
final seconds here's grant other end
gets by the defense man and jams it in
pretty play here joker jazz 28
harness yourselves in for the fourth
quarter let's see if this one's denver
let's see if it holds up
oh nice pass inside
wow what a pass by kawhi leonard
zubotz with a pretty play to finish
with authority inside and took one high
that time for millsap
mills have late on the rotation here
mike d'antoni
citing personal reasons and that's all
he would give
on daniel house he did say it was not
covert related
oh anthony davis on a beautiful set up
from rondo together he just steps up
pj tucker starts to front rondo throws
it up over the top
just a beautiful pass right on the money
right over jeff green
rondo controlling it and his pocket
picked by covington
covington's so good at that one of the
top steels man
and westbrook on the law from hardin
you have to go james harden finding his
running buddy russell westbrook on the
lob houston 10 points off
la's eight turnovers tonight and a five
point lead
hardin shakes lebron james and comes up
short into the hands of davis now the
lakers on the run
to lebron lebron all the way freight
train coming lebron james
lebron out on the run he's usually the
guy leading the fast break and making
the pass but here
anthony dave and now lebron james on the
floor
covington still grabbing at his jaw it
looks like
up top for davis the second time tonight
gotta get one up quick gordon shot fake
puts it on the deck
and it's knocked away by caruso up ahead
rondo all the way lebron james
throws it down that was risky here late
in this game
man this was ill-advised defensive
player that
pat beverly is jamal murray goes to work
oh what a great
spin move and a jackhammer inside by
leonard
you're right i'm gonna ask in a second
who before all this began was your pick
oh he'll troll pour that in
pretty play by leonard as he took it off
that baseline
final team look at this as he just put
it back up and through
with a lot of congestion around wallet
miami has numbers if they want it now
tice back into the action
bam great spin move and says it with his
chest inside
this is a group that's going to grind
and compete and keep
coming and bam says all right mr
wannamaker you're not big enough strong
game with caruso good pass and james
hammers one home i would say he's
yeah okay is that still a drip gets the
little
alley pass from caruso and the finish
from the king two of seven
five points we talked about michael
porter junior the thrilling scorer
as anthony davis oh my goodness rondo
was just putting on the show
boy these two wow they've got anything
but normal in this nba bubble
shot blocked jalen brown throws it right
back at dragons
here's tatum runs oh and throws it down
first runs in the crowder and then the
hammer now the celtics up by
five or but this is a heck of a move by
dragach and a tremendous recovery
by jalen brown and
jason tatum
here's rondo for three can't get it to
go
murray with the rebound
denver trying to add to it murray goes
all the way in
[ __ ] it back and throws it down
and the mean mug is out for murray and
the nuggets
shot clock at four james
and he'll settle for the two and can't
get the follow but
that is howard with a follow in the foul
he's got 10 rebounds already very rarely
do you see red sorry a guy tip dunk and
get the foul
adebayo drives down the lane and the
flush
wow i don't know he's a right-handed
player who wants to drive left
and there's two shooters acres by one
three and a half gone by second quarter
here in game three
alley-oop to davis rajon rondo once
again with a pass from just
inside half court he starts him up
jay crowder with poor body position he
spins out
no ball pressure on rondo passing it's
just
exceptional came in as a terrific
defender
his offensive game has improved leaps
and bounds as james throws it down
adebayo pass inside through it behind
robinson
james floats it up and anthony davis
with the one-handed tomahawk
lakers go up by three
a good pass and finish by anthony
davis and then boom running the floor
up three great spirit defense
back to james james goes inside the
flush and the foul
and going back to caruso mike after that
spectacular drive and finish by james
about to play the pass and lebron james
about to win another title